[موسيقى]
اخبار عمليه طوفان الاقصى بايجاز من قطاع
غزه اهلا بكم عمليه طوفان الاقصى تدخل
يومها الثاني ارتفاع عدد القتلى الى اكثر
من 600 اسرائيلي واكثر من 2000 جريح
ونتنياهو يصدق رسميا على اعلان حاله الحرب
بينما تواصل قوته شن غارات على مناطق
مختلفه في غزه ووزاره الصحه في القطاع
تقول ان حصيله العدوان الاسرائيلي وصلت
الى اكثر من 350 شهيد واكثر من 2000 جرييه
وفي جنوب لبنان حزب الله يعلن استهدافه
ثلاثه مواقع للاحتلال الاسرائيلي في مزارع
شبعه المحتله وقصفها باعداد كبيره من
القذائف المدفعيه والصواريخ الموجهه
بالمقابل قال الجيش الاسرائيلي انه قصف
المنطقه التي اطلقت منها القذائف معلنا
استعداده للتعامل مع كل الاحتمالات وعلى
كافه الجبهات من جهتها قالت اليونيفل انها
تتواصل مع الاطراف المعنيه كافه لاحتواء
الموقف وفي مصر وزاره الخارجيه
الاسرائيليه تعلن عن مقتل سائحين
اسرائيليين في مدينه الاسكندريه ومصادر
امنيه مصريه تقول ان منفذ الهجوم شرطي
مصري اطلق النار من سلاحه الشخصي وتؤكد
انه تم القبض عليه فورا فيما اعلن محامون
مصريون التطوع للدفاع عن الشرطي وعلى صعيد
ردود الفعل الدوليه المتواصله بشان عمليه
طوفان الاقصى وعد الرئيس الامريكي جو
بايدن بدعم بلاده لاسرائيل واستنكر الرئيس
الفرنسي ايميلين ماكرون بشده الهجمات على
اسرائيل وعبر عن تضامنه معها في حين اكد
رئيس وزراء بريطانيا على حق اسرائيل
المطلق في الدفاع عن نفسها وشاركه نفس
الموقف الرئيس الاوكراني الذي وصف عناصر
المقاومه بالارهابيين ايضا الى
اللقاء y